yo what's up guys prestige you today was
so and today I'm going to be doing a
little Bob spotlights going to be
bleeped chill relaxed one it's a not a
to advance mod and yay let's get right
into it now this mod is called battle
music and it's simple mod starts off
their vanilla you can add a little more
to it and yeah i'll just show you what
it does it's battle music so i think you
should know what it does someone's like
i'm gonna show you this is a GUI so this
is how music completely off you see it's
not that exciting I'm all right I'm all
right all right now battle music on I
also go to some drums and bass alright
so shush George are so that's basically
what it does and don't worry there's a
lot more of that coming up I just want
to show you you start off with just the
twilight princess and then you can get
drum bass drum bass kingdom hearts and
more packs from the website you can just
go over here and click Launch name
brother see that's pretty basic and
that's basically everything I had
there's not much else I cannot talk
about in the mods and just go check out
yourselves and now I'll show you each
one of the different mods and why
there's so much better than normal
minecraft sounds I might I sure i'm
probably going to be using this pot from
now on so guys if you enjoyed this video
leave like crate and agree like it
subscribe so see you later enjoy
you